if I have the option to see something in  IMAX I always will I love IMAX I love  the experience of it it's my chance to  prove myself this is definitely a movie  that is worth your time to see it in the  IMAX everyone big what I think yeah like  a biggest perience  was like not just like the screens but  like the music it was all antennas the  whole movie is it's a giant movie that's  why it would be great I'll see you on  IMS because I was like you know you're  used to seeing it all oh like I feel  like you're going to be inside the world  because I knew like you just watching a  regular theater was lynched like yeah  like so immersive it was crazy  I mean the action is so awesome and  intense whoo that was awesome  it blew me away it absolutely blew me  away the sound design for this movie is  incredible  the CGI for this movie is like a work of  art and it's definitely something that  you want to appreciate on a big screen  you  you